[Music]
hello everyone its Perry back here in
Park City with another Collider
exclusive interview we right now are in
Park City of course at the Kia supper
sweet big thanks to Kia for making all
this happen so we could talk to the team
behind farewell and more congratulations
guys thank you I imagine you had a
wonderful day yesterday at the premiere
it was pretty magical I cannot wait to
see this one act where we have to start
with you here because I'm gonna get the
question that you're gonna hear time and
time again over with first because a lot
of our viewers do not know what the
movie is about would you mind giving the
brief synopsis yeah so our film
farewell amour is a story about a family
Angolan immigrants who've been separated
for 17 years due to visa immigration
issues so at the top of the story
they're finally reunited and are now
challenged with having to rediscover one
another and what they've turned into
after you know the long distance apart
and using the tool of dance as a way to
reunite I was reading that you had made
a prequel short to this was that kind of
done as a proof of concept to get the
feature off the ground yes it was a
short film that I'd worked on some years
ago won a cash prize and required that I
shoot another short and knowing that I'd
wanted to work on a feature for this my
producer and I decided to use that cash
prize to make a proof of concept for the
feature so then what happens from there
because I often find that you know you
come up with the intentions to make a
film but then getting the greenlight is
a different story and their hits this
point where you lock this one little
thing that kind of makes it feel real
like you're really going so what was
that thing for you that really got this
off the ground well I mean the proof of
concept was pretty powerful in in that
regard and sort of not just proof of
concept that we can shoot a film but in
terms of sort of what the mood and feel
of the story was so that in combination
with the synopsis and you know all the
budget stuff and whatever
what we were about to do was very very
useful in terms of getting us into the
door of a lot of the development labs
that we got into including Sundance
Feature Film development ah I always
loved hearing about that process because
the Sundance labs are definitely
something special so absolutely
congratulations for going through that
process it's a wonderful thing can you
tell me a little bit about bringing your
ensemble together now is it kind of a
wide-ranging search did you know any of
them in advance how did that go
yeah and Tyra and I have been friends
for a while we actually met on the film
festival route years ago both of us had
Ansari is also a filmmaker and both of
us had a short film in a festival
together and had been swearing and sort
of like yeah we should work together one
of these days we should work together
one of these days and so when this came
up actually been for the prequel the
short prequel I had asked him to work on
it I had absolutely no money at that
time he lived in LA so I wasn't able to
bring him to New York to shoot it but
for the feature I was like you know I
think this would be really really great
for you and so he was gracious enough to
send us an audition headshot so I could
you know share it with my producers and
things like that and that's how entire
came on board yeah I love hearing when
people meet at a festival and yes I mean
that's part of the point of being here
and we'd been collaborators for a while
and that was really sweet
seinem is somebody I've known from the
theater world in New York for a while
and just seen her work and we've also
bumped into each other at the same film
festivals and just kind of like hey how
you doing but when we did because we did
have auditions we had a casting director
and we did hold auditions in New York
and surprisingly there weren't a lot of
there were a lot of people were very
intimidated by the role that signed-up
plays of Esther largely because of the
accent requirements and it's just it was
a very dense role and so you know she
completely knocked it out of the park
and my casting director was like you
definitely want you definitely want to
have sign up and we're just so so
pleased
that happened yeah
and Jamie also came through casting that
was the one rule that we knew was not
going to be an offer was going to be a
new discovery and it had a lot of
requirements to it too
because the person the needed to have
dance ability they needed to be able to
do accents they needed to be we make one
in somebody who was over 18 but could
play under 18 and she came in through
casting and just completely blew us away
and similarly our casting director was
like she's about to be a star you
definitely want to take her like don't
even think twice so Jamie did you have
intentions of becoming an actor or was
your background mostly dance
conservatory training for theater I just
like to move and I pick up African style
dancing really well it just fits in my
body but I'm not trained at all this one
is the trained dancer here so yeah so
first feature film I'm wondering having
been through the process now and moving
on to other projects if you could go
back to the very beginning of this one
and give yourself one piece of advice
having been through the experience what
would it be
I don't know because the experience
truly was amazing working with all of
them because starting off I was so
scared oh so nervous
because like you said it was all these
requirements of like you have to have
this and go on accident which is very
difficult and you have to be able to do
kuduro which is like extremely difficult
and and being that is my first film I
was I was so scared and with these
actors they're incredible and they were
just so gracious and so kind on set and
it made for a really great experience so
I don't know that I would necessarily
even change anything the way it how it
all went about was exactly what it
needed to be so as I know we were just
hearing a little bit about how the role
could be intimidating because of the
accent and and I'm sure that was a big
challenge but was there anything as the
process kind of went along that you
discovered about the character that you
didn't expect
to be a challenge as the film progressed
not really I think the only thing that
became a little bit concerning for me
because I wanted to get it right without
deeply religious she is and I am NOT a
particularly fervent person in that
sense and and I want it was it was
really important for me to find a way of
portraying her beliefs without making it
unintentionally funny you know what I
mean because she because of her
religious fervor and the way the
constant praying the constant
invitations and all that and in I didn't
want it to be to come across as
something that's comic because it's it's
a deeply felt and deeply believed thing
for a lot of people and my grandmother
was a very very religious person and I
have family members like that and I have
friends who have a deep faith and belief
and I didn't want to make light of that
and he could easily have gone into that
territory so it was very hard to tread a
delicate line there can you guys talk a
little bit about developing an on-screen
relationship because it's a unique
scenario where your characters are
separated for such a significant portion
of their relationship and we don't
really see that kind of history
portrayed on screen very often so I'm
not sure if you've done on screen
relationships like that before so what
was it about having history where the
two people were together the entire time
versus the situation in this movie where
they're separated that might have been
maybe a little more difficult to have
that history come through oh I feel like
I've had a long-distance relationship in
my imagination with zeyneb for a long
time because I've been a huge fan of
hers for a long time so just played
right into that so having to deal with
the reality when we can face-to-face but
I having this history of knowing her
work and being a fan of her work for so
long it fit with the storyline so for me
that that was my way in
[Laughter]
building the relationship for me was
like equals it was written such a
beautiful piece anyway that there wasn't
that much work he just had to just say
the words it was just there on the page
but also I come from an immigrant family
too and I'm familiar with you know
relatives who have gone away and they're
waiting for the other person to join and
then that person it doesn't work out for
some reason and then in some cases you
hear of that person falling in love with
someone else and then trying to keep
that relationship separate or not
knowing how to deal with both these
elements so I drew from life experience
not personal life experience but from
watching you know from stories I've
heard relatives have seen and yeah that
was mainly the way of building it
watching my parents you both kind of
touched on this little but Jamie and if
you want to add to this equi I'm would
love to hear from you but one of the
things from your director statement that
really stood out to me was when you say
that the circumstances may differ but
the themes are universal in this story
and I really do think that that's a way
to convey a unique situation to
everybody where it could really sink in
and become deeply personal no matter who
you are and it's a powerful thing so for
you Jamie what what is the connection
there for you is there that deeply
personal connection where maybe you
can't relate to this specific occurrence
but something else you know made you tap
into this story in a personal manner for
me I can with the people that I grew up
with as well we can relate to families
being separated not necessarily because
of immigration it could be because of
and you talked about this it could be
because of incarceration it could be
because of military I grew up in a
military family and so I could relate to
that separation of not seeing that
father for such a long time and
believing that this is a man that is
meant to provide for the family but he
hasn't been in my life for 17 years and
so that was quite easy to tap into and
quite profound to experience and to go
through that
yeah it's very very powerful element to
it yeah I mean aside from those I think
I think what was quite surprising to me
was just how broad the points of contact
were for a lot of different people after
even just pitching the story or at some
point reading the script just random
people that we met you know who seemed
to be very well-off in life or you know
from various walks of life not all
Africans not even all necessarily
immigrants but had some sort of touch
point of like this has happened to me in
some way
through you know my immigrant
grandparents or through you know the
nanny that you know looks after us or
you know my neighbor who or my bus
driver that you know I I always thought
they just enjoyed being away from their
family for some reason and now I
discovered this that and the other you
know so it was it was actually quite
surprising to find how many across the
board how many people could actually
really relate to it on a personal level
yeah I'm sure you guys are probably
feeling it in the room a little
yesterday weird can you tell me a little
bit about your process as an actor's
director onset and obviously everyone
can speak to this you know we have
someone with a theatre background and
I'm sure you each have your own
different process so what is it that you
like to do and how do you adjust to
every single person in their personal
needs yeah I don't if I just attend you
know because I wrote this script what's
useful for me in terms of being able to
ground myself and so that I'm able to
support them on onset when we're
shooting is to know as much backstory as
possible you know and so that was an
exercise that I went through while I was
you know researching and working on the
script and then about a month before we
started working together I started
working with a dialect coach and
explaining you know working with her to
to decide what it is that we want
to do with because it was very important
to me the authenticity was very
important to me and so with dialect it's
you know people in Angola I'm not from
uncle I've never been I don't speak
Portuguese and neither did any of my
actors and neither did the dialect coach
either so she had a wholes you know
research that she needed to do and then
what part of uncle are they from and
what is their class background and
therefore what do they sound like is
this a college educated person or not is
this you know what kind of families do
they come from and cetera that you know
and so all of those things and then
because there's a music and a dance
element what kind of music do they
listen to what what era of me you know
so listening to certain music for
particular eras within on Cola and and
music that was the sin to buy a lot of
on Galanos who were abroad during the
civil war and what was popular then and
so all of that information when they
show it out I was just like here's you
know stacks and stacks of information to
have fun guys you know and having them
understand the civil war and what that
was and you know watching documentaries
and listening to me as I had a you know
Spotify playlist for all of them and you
know so that was useful for me I don't
know but it was amazing because coming
from a theatre background that's what we
used to getting all the information all
the research materials and that allows
us to like really delve deep into the
character and find and create a person
and so it was almost like working with a
theatre director actually you know like
table work and reading it's really rare
to find that that extent you know that
amount of work table work before film
you know you remember he was saying you
usually just meet the day off and there
you go and we had weeks for me yeah I
found it very useful to have to sit down
and like we talked about what the
background was and what the history was
and again those playlists were extremely
helpful for me because music is a way in
for me a lot of times with characters
and to get just the soundscape of of
that really helps just delve in
and also to figure out what is this 17
year old girl from Angola listen to what
is that how does that influence the way
you know she moves about in this new
country what is that familiarity you
know so yeah so this does sound like a
very special unique collaboration so
Jamie I'm wondering for you because a
lot of Batman fans out there what can
you take from this process as your first
feature film and kind of hold tight to
what equus given you as an actor's
director also and bring - you know an
enormous big studio project like that
echo had a lot of trust in us - there
wasn't a lot of like hands like just
like trying to shape us to do anything
she really trusted us with her work
which I thank you for and that in turn
just gave me a bit of confidence of
being able to show up and be like okay I
know what I'm doing even though I just
graduated but I know what I'm doing I
can I can show up and just be president
and Trust the work so that's the biggest
thing that I'm gonna take from from this
whole experience yeah and can you tease
at all how it's been I'm a huge fan of
Reeves and I think Robert Pattinson is
just like a next-level individual so
what is your collaboration been like
with them and if they brought anything
out of you that you didn't even think
you were capable of yourself well we
haven't we haven't really started yet so
it's just it's more so we're getting
ready to start in a couple weeks so I'm
excited to get get over there and and
start that collaboration with them
that's so exciting we got so many
viewers out there who are so thrilled
for you so wishing you all the best on
that I got a lot of faith thank you all
so much for your time today big
congratulations again on the movie and
being part of Sundance this year thank
you to everybody out there watching this
interview do not leave it without liking
and sharing it keep an eye out for
farewell and more also a big thanks to
the fine folks at Kia we are so happy to
be part of the supper suite this year
the collider studio is in full swing
right now we're gonna have so many more
interviews coming your way real soon